YOU LOOK LIKE YOU ARE DOING
OKAY.
>> Jesse: I'M READY FOR THE
WEEKEND.
FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
APPOINTED A SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP IN TWO SEPARATE
CRIMINAL PROBES.
>> INVESTIGATION INTO WHETHER
ANY BEN SHAPIRO OR ENTITY
UNLAWFULLY INTERFERED WITH THE
TRANSFER OF POWER FOLLOWING THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION OR
THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE VOTE HELD ON
OR ABOUT JANUARY 6TH, 2021.
THE SECOND IS THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND OTHER PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS AS WELL AS THE POSSIBLE
OBSTRUCTION OF THAT
INVESTIGATION.
>> Jesse: BUT, HERE'S THE THING,
JANUARY 6TH HAPPENED TWO YEARS
AGO.
AND THIS DOCUMENT CASE HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR ALMOST THE SAME
AMOUNT OF TIME SO WHY ARE THEY
APPOINTING A SPECIAL COUNSEL
NOW?
BASED ON RECENT DEVELOPMENTS,
INCLUDING THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT HE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT IN THE
NEXT ELECTION, AND THE SITTING
PRESIDENT'S STATED INTENTION TO
BE A CANDIDATE AS WELL, I HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT IT IS IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Jesse: SO TRUMP ANNOUNCES IS
HE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AND THE
REPUBLICANS TAKE THE HOUSE AND
TEE UP INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE
.IDEN FAMILY
WHAT ARE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY
VOTERS SUPPOSED TO DO?
THIS HAS TO FACTOR INTO THE
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY.
IS THIS AN INTERFERENCE IN
DEMOCRACY?
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THAT.
AND, IF ANYBODY ELSE GETS INTO
THE PRIMARY, THEY ARE GOING TO
SAY DO YOU WANT TO VOTE FOR A
GUY WHO IS BEING INVESTIGATED BY
A THOUSAND DIFFERENT
PROSECUTORS?
OR DOES TRUMP SAY:  SEE, I'M THE
DEMOCRATS' BIGGEST THREAT.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING TO STOP
ME.
AND BY GOING AFTER ME, THEY ARE
REALLY GOING AFTER YOU.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION TOOK
ABOUT TWO YEARS TO FIGURE OUT
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
THE GARLAND SAYS THIS ONE IS
GOING TO BE QUICK.
>> I WILL ENSURE THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL RECEIVES THE
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT THIS WORK
QUICKLY AND COMPLETELY.
>> Jesse: I WOULD HATE TO KNOW
WHAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
DEFINITION OF QUICK IS
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, JACK SMITH, ISN'T
COMING BACK TO AMERICA FOR A
WHILE.
HE GOT INTO A LITTLE BICYCLE
ACCIDENT OVER IN THE NETHERLANDS
AND HE NEEDS TIME TO HEAL, SO WE
ARE OFF TO A GREAT START.
MEANWHILE, THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
THEY HAD NO IDEA ANY OF THIS WAS
GOING DOWN.
>> WAS THE PRESIDENT AWARE OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S DECISION
TO NAME A SPECIAL COUNSEL?
>> SO JUST FOR A SECOND JUST
TELL YOU NO HE WAS NOT AWARE.
WE WERE NOT AWARE.
AS YOU KNOW, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE MAKES DECISIONS ABOUT
ITS CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
INDEPENDENTLY.
WE ARE NOT INVOLVED.
WE ARE NOT -- WE HAVE NOT BEEN
BE AWARE ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
INVESTIGATION OR ANY CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> Jesse: THE LAST TIME THE
WHITE HOUSE SAID THEY DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT AN INVESTIGATION WAS
WHEN THE FBI RAISED MAR-A-LAGO,
REMEMBER?
BIDEN'S HANDLERS HID HIM FROM
THE PRESS FOR A FEW DAYS WHILE
FLUNKIES SAID THE PRESS DIDN'T
KNOW A THING?
THEN BIDEN WAS DIRECTLY
IMPLICATED IN THE RAID AFTER IT
CAME OUT THAT THE ACTING
NATIONAL ARCHIVEST, REMEMBER THE
PERSNICKETY LIBRARIAN ACTUALLY
WENT TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
ASKED THE WHITE HOUSE TO WAIVE
TRUMP'S EXDETECTIVE PRIVILEGE
AND BIDEN WAIVED IT?
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT'S ANNOUNCED THE DAY AFTER THE
REPUBLICANS TEE UP AN
INVESTIGATION INTO BIDEN OVER
HIS FAMI